[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous lundi 11 juin lors du 7-8
journal sur tv 60,18 bienvenue dans
cette nouvelle semaine d'information
locale
tout de suite les titres de cette
édition ils sont mobilisés depuis la
nuit dernière comme sur plusieurs sites
en france les agriculteurs ont débuté un
blocage de la raffinerie de coignières
le mouvement pourrait durer trois jours
pour dénoncer l'action du gouvernement
et notamment sur une décision concernant
l'importation d'huile de palme pour les
biocarburants explication est la merise
attrape accueille demain les phases
finales du cycle mythe 2018 le
championnat inter collèges de match
d'improvisation théâtrale et les élèves
de quatre établissements de saint
quentin en yvelines se feront face pour
remporter la victoire
un événement porté par l'association
déclic théâtre nous en parlons avec nos
invités
enfin elle débute ce jeudi en russie
c'est bien sûr la coupe du monde de
football toute cette semaine la
rédaction de tv 60,18 vous propose une
série de reportages sur le sujet et
l'engouement nonce vous le verrez auprès
des supporters yvelinois des bleus dans
ce journal deux invités également du
code skis du conseil de développement de
saint quentin en yvelines
il organise demain son assemblée
plénière et les jeunes seront au coeur
des débats
ça sera tout à l'heure dans journal ces
images impressionnantes
d'abord un intense orage a concerné les
yvelines en fin de journée hier et des
chutes de grêle comme vous le voyez ici
dans la vallée de chevreuse certaines
zones ont été également inondé ce
week-end notamment à rambouillet les
yvelines toujours placé ce lundi soir en
vigilance orange aux orages par
météo-france l'alertent l'alertent cours
jusqu'à minuit au moins avec quelques
conseils de comportement ne vous abritez
pas sous les arbres
évitez les promenades en forêt éviter
également d'utiliser des appareils
électriques dehors au moment de l'orage
signaler enfin sans attendre tout
départs de feux dont vous pourriez être
témoins pour eux le gouvernement fait
preuve d'incohérence les agriculteurs
bloquent depuis la nuit dernière l'accès
à une quinzaine de raffineries et dépôts
de carburant partout en france
parmi ces sites celui de coignières
motifs d'opposition notamment est la
décision
du gouvernement d'autoriser total
importé 300 mille tonnes d'huile de
palme revenant et d'asie est les détails
et précisions avec nicolas kirillovitch
et les images sont signés patrick
jacques de dixmude des tas de terre et
de fumier déverser des deux heures du
matin à coignières et un accès à la
raffinerie rendu impossible la fnsea et
les jeunes agriculteurs ont débuté cette
nuit leur bras de fer contre le
gouvernement il s'oppose à
l'autorisation accordée à total pour
importés d'asie de l'huile de palme pour
eux ces livraisons promises pour
l'ouverture d'une nouvelle raffinerie
mettrait à mal la filière française de
biocarburants et ne respecterait pas non
plus les règles environnementales
on a eu tellement de choses qui nous ont
été eux
qu'ils nous ont été reprochés au niveau
environnemental par les différents
gouvernements successifs
on s'y adapte systématiquement est
aujourd'hui en fait le gouvernement nous
fait un beau pied de nez matinale aussi
la réponse du ministre de l'agriculture
sur rtl stéphane travert indique que le
gouvernement ne reviendra pas sur
l'accord avec total pour lui ces
blocages sont illégaux depuis que
j'occupe ce ministère nous avons
toujours été dans une étroite
concertation dans le dialogue
mais ce dialogue il doit être franc moi
je dis qu'aujourd'hui ces blocages sont
sont illégaux et que ce n'est pas en
bloquant des raffineries que l'on
retrouvera les solutions adéquates tout
simplement sujet environnemental
sensible au sein même de la majorité
il y a une dizaine de jours le député
yvelinois bruno myle yens interpeller
l'exécutif sur le sujet comment
aurions-nous peut nous poser en leader
mondial de la cause environnementale et
en même temps favoriser de telles
importations
la fnsea et les jeunes agriculteurs
prévoit pour le moment un blocage des
raffineries pour trois jours mais menace
déjà le mouvement sera reconduit
jusqu'au recul du gouvernement
un rendez vous est prévu demain au
ministère de l'agriculture
autre mobilisation celle des cheminots a
la sncf la grève reprend demain mardi
pour deux jours pour les lignes de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et les
prévisions indiquent un trafic réduit de
moitié 1 train sur 2 pour les reverser
ainsi que les lignes n ai eu les
horaires de vos trains sur le site
transilien.com vendredi c'était la
journée d'hommage aux français morts en
indochine la préfecture des yvelines en
a profité pour décorer et 12 personnes
de la croix du combattant
cette distinction récompense ceux qui
sont se sont illustrés dans les opex les
opérations extérieures dans le jargon
militaire c'est-à-dire à l'étranger
écoutez ces quelques réactions le monde
n'est pas sûr
et que nos armées continuent à défendre
notre liberté partout dans le monde y
compris dans la période contemporaine
c'est un grand honneur pour moi fait
par rapport aux 6,1 tous mes camarades
en fait qui ont servi au même moment et
d'autres qui ont servi avant et qui
serviront après je mesure en fait
heures que c'est que d'avoir cette
médaille que voilà beaucoup ont dû
batailler plus que moi ce que j'ai pu
faire donc
voilà quand c'est de maintenir comment
inciter les jeunes à rester sur le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
la question sera posée et demain à la
salle du conseil communautaire de
trappes le coc des skis et organise son
assemblée plénière le thème à tous
jeunes vivre étudier travailler sortir à
saint quentin en yvelines pour parler de
cette thématique l2 invités avec moi en
plateau ils seront deux animateurs du
groupe jeunesse au co des skis francis
hidalgo et jean claude yvon consorts
messieurs bonsoir
alors le code esquisses et le conseil de
développement de saint quentin en
yvelines première question pourquoi
consacrer cette assemblée plénière à la
jeunesse eh bien nous travaillons depuis
l'an dernier sur les sujets comme le
projet ce territoire où le plan local de
l'habitat intercommunale et en ces
travaux là nous avons identifié une
double problématique au niveau des
jeunes d'une part un déficit entre 20 et
30 les 18 30 ans qui partent de saint
quentin et ceux qui viennent vivre à 55
qui s'installe à saint quentin d'accord
en proportion ce qui veut dire que la
population du jeune baisse par rapport à
l'ensemble de la population et salles
depuis les années 2000
et puis une difficulté qu'ont les
entreprises pour engager les jeunes pour
leur établissement 50e si on fait un
point sur la jeunesse notamment sur les
étudiants il ya quinze à seize mille
étudiants qui viennent chaque année sur
le territoire de saint quentin en
yvelines 14 résidences étudiantes sur le
territoire est ce que du point de vue
purement étudiants on ne parle pas des
jeunes en général mais du point de vue
purement étudiants est ce que c'est un
territoire attractif
saint quentin en yvelines eh bien c'est
la question qu'on peut se poser en tout
cas les jeunes étudiants viennent
viennent à la faculté
mais est ce qu'ils y habitent nous n'en
avons pas la certitude
donc nous avons dans le cadre du propre
projet plan local de la visa fait des
propositions pour essayer de remédier à
ce manque de connaissance du lieu
d'habitat des étudiants ça a été
soulignée par le cos des skis lors du de
la phase diagnostic de ce plan local
intercommunal plaindre habitat
intercommunale
il va manquer du logement pour les
jeunes d'ici les prochaines années sur
le territoire
il consiste hidalgo il ya plusieurs
thèmes de questionnements en dehors du
logement on s'aperçoit bien sûr que les
jeunes ont énormément de mal à se loger
ça c'est une des problématiques la
deuxième problématique c'est le problème
des déplacements
d'accord c'est difficile de se déplacer
surtout le soir et le troisième sujet
qui nous préoccupe c'est tout ce qui est
la vie au quotidien la sociabilité
c'est très difficile pour un jeune de
s'implanter à saint quentin
quand le soir principalement il n'y a
pas beaucoup d'animations possible pour
eux c'est ça c'est un problème que vous
le dites de transport d'animation il n'y
a pas assez d'offres de sorties
culturelles de loisirs sur le territoire
il ya un problème de logement il ya un
problème d'offre de convivialité si
j'ose dire et de déplacement c'est les
trois problématiques qui qui nous
paraissent importants c'est pour ça
qu'on a ouvert cette assemblée générale
et où on veut absolument recueillir la
parole des jeunes parce que nous ne sont
pas des experts on recueille la parole
des jeunes même s'ils osent ils viennent
demain cette assemblée est primordial
mais cette assemblée est notre but c'est
qu'ils deviennent acteurs en recueille
lac la parole il faut qu'ensemble on
puisse trouver des pistes de réflexion
qu'on mettra ensuite en réflexion plus
longue vous lisiez demain cette
assemblée c'est le fruit d'une année de
travail c'est ça au sein du groupe
jeunesse du col et ce qu'ils ont que les
problématiques que nous venons d'évoquer
c'est seule que nous avons analysé nous
nous voulons vérifier auprès des jeunes
que ce sont les brûler vraie
problématique
donc nous abordons ces trois sujets mais
tout autre sujet pourrait être abordé
demain nous voulons absolument c'est
écouter les jeunes là c'est leur donner
nous voulons leur donner l'occasion de
s'exprimer sur les difficultés de vie
de travail et de le vivre en général de
se loger et s'amuser à cinq enfants
l'objectif trouver vraiment demain des
solutions écouter ces jeunes par le
débat par leur parler échanger et
trouver des solutions on va créer trois
ateliers avec les problématiques qu'on a
abordé dans nos radote pour le mée matic
notre propos ici on a appelé notre
rencontre à tout jeune c'est parce qu'on
considère que les jeunes sont nos atouts
de demain donc on est là pour recueillir
leurs interrogations et 6 et d'élaborer
des que des pistes de réflexion qu'on va
soumettre ensuite me séduit politique
aussi justement il faut il faut cet
appui des élus pour cette thématique
la jeunesse est un problème primordial
pour l'ensemble des territoires
donc c'est vrai que ça va s'intégrer
dans le projet de territoire dont qui
ont un travail de réflexion des pistes
de réflexions qui seront soumises aux
élus et qui je pense sera intégrée dans
le projet de territoire
une dernière question comment on
participe demain à cette assemblée
plénière et bien il est prudent de
s'inscrire sur ww ce qui pourrait faire
cela tout jeune
ça se passe au conseil communautaire à 4
rue des charmes à trappes
tous les jeunes sont un fils et vous
avez parlé d'étudiants mais y'a pas que
les étudiants s'élargir il ya les jeunes
qui travaillent à 5 enfin les jeunes qui
aimeraient venir travailler à saint
quentin
des jeunes qui charge qui travaille à
saint quentin qu'on y habite qu'on n'y
habitent pas trop d'années ils ont 18 30
ans 18 18 ans et l'allongement et on
voudrait pas se bloquer uniquement sur
les jeunes on a besoin aussi de
recueillir la parole d'acteurs qui sont
en contact direct avec les jeunes
donc le monde économique les les foyers
de jeunes travailleurs et que c est donc
le site pour avoir plus d'information
pour s'inscrire à cette assemblée
plénière s'affiche en bas de l'écran
merci francis hidalgo et jean claude
hibon d'avoir été avec nous je rappelle
que vous êtes co animateur du groupe
jeunesse au codis qui le conseil de
développement de saint quentin en
yvelines
un projet qui concerne les jeunes
justement au lycée jean vilar de plaisir
depuis deux ans trois professeurs ont
lancé une web radio les élèves
deviennent le temps d'un enregistrement
rédacteur en chef ou encore chroniqueurs
un travail qui mêle journalisme et
enseignement scolaire clémence tergnier
et mélanie poker ont assisté à une
émission
breitenau éditeur vous êtes bien sûr
jeunes la radio aujourd'hui nous allons
donc lavage et plus précisément à son
abolition
malena et la présentatrice du jour avec
ses chroniqueurs
elle parle de l' esclavage d'hier et
d'aujourd'hui pour la webradio du lycée
jean vilar de plaisir s'est présenté
vers l'introduction présenter toutes les
personnes qui vont parler c'est faire
les transitions conclure poser des
questions à chaque personne chaque
groupe et chacun est juge et la
présentatrice en herbe fait partie des
29 élèves de cette classe de seconde qui
travaille sur la web radio depuis un
trimestre ah ouais c'est stressant
stressant mais je suis habitué une fois
qu'on est on parle tout tout tout se
passe bien ce projet de radio 100%
lycéenne s'inscrit dans le cadre de
l'éducation aux médias et à
l'information
les jeunes sont sensibilisés à la
réalisation d'un travail de groupe
le format de la radio c'est intéressant
parce que ça permet de travailler
plusieurs compétences en amont la
recherche documentaire donc c'est pour
ça qu'on travaille au cdi
ça demande aussi un travail d'écriture
d'expression écrite puisque avant d'être
dit le texte est écrit
donc aussi une règle travail sur la
correction de la langue classe aussi le
moyen de faire travailler un
d'expression orale tous les élèves
puisque tous les élèves passent devant
le micro
lancée en 2016 par une professeure de
sciences économiques et sociales elle
est disponible en podcast sur le site du
lycée jean vilar eux sont au collège des
élèves d'établissements saint quentinois
seront engagés demain mardi dans les
phases finales du cycle 2018 19e édition
de ce championnat intercollèges de match
d'improvisation théâtrale s'est passé à
partir de 20h30 à la merise attrape pour
en parler et plusieurs invités autour de
la table avec moi est lourd et yakin
wismond soir bonsoir
vous êtes le responsable du secteur
improvisation à déclic théâtre qui
organise cet événement alors demain il y
aura deux demi finales au programme
avant la grande finale d'abord le
collège youri gagarine de trappes qui
sera opposé à la mare au sol à
coignières et deuxième demi finale
le collège des prés à montigny le
bretonneux qui sera opposé à la géo à
elancourt nous recevons également
d'ailleurs deux élèves de la géo à
elancourt donc meriem luiz est élu cargo
bonsoir à vous deux on va faire un petit
tour de table par vous de on va
commencer par vous de cette interview
comment vous sentez-vous à un jour cette
cette demi-finale meriem ben c'est on a
un peu peur mais on dit qu'on va y aller
enfin on veut pas perdre et on dit que
le motiver mais on a peur quand même lui
tient parce que vous avez peur également
j'ai pas peur mais je suis un peu
stressé parce que on l'attend ça fait
deux ans qu'on trois ans que fait dieu
l'impro d'accord et on espère cette
année on va remporter la coupe
qu'est ce que ça représente
l'improvisation pour pour tous les deux
lucas bah pour moi c'est un loisir est
ce que j'aime et meriem un loisir aussi
c'est un m'occupe alors noël yakine
l'improvisation c'est l'une des
signatures bien sûr déclic théâtre vous
organisez le site mine depuis près de
vingt ans maintenant pourquoi ça compte
l'improvisation pour pour déclic théâtre
ça compte parce que depuis les 19 ans
qu'on organise ce cycle mythe on a
rencontré
des personnes qui sont devenus adultes
et qui aujourd'hui voilà on
on à défendre on a des fratries on a des
filiations comme ça qui sont dans des
familles donc en termes de culture
locale nous on sait qu'on est on est
inscrit dans le patrimoine de saint
quentin en yvelines
et c'est vrai que le cycle mythe c'est
l'un des premiers l'un des premiers
piliers en fait de tout ça je pense sur
lequel on arrive vraiment à établir un
certain nombre de deux choses de record
quelque part d'existence et de et de
fait d'avoir autant de personnes qui
participent à des activités
d'improvisation théâtrale
il disait un loisir l'improvisation ça
permet quoi ça peut permettre de révéler
les talents révélés des personnalités
aussi la whey ils ont raison c'est avant
tout un loisir mois gérer surtout une
pratique dans laquelle on prend
énormément de plaisir parce que
finalement on fait pas nécessairement du
théâtre dans un premier temps
nécessairement du sport c'est une vraie
rencontre entre les deux où il n'y a pas
la difficulté d'apprendre un texte où il
n'y a pas la difficulté du physique à
tout prix dont énormément donné des
éléments peuvent s'y retrouver là où ils
se retrouvent pas dans l'une ou l'autre
des disciplines et puis donc c'est avant
tout et ils sont dans le plaisir dans le
plaisir de partager la ils disent qu'ils
aimeraient gagner bien sûr tout le monde
a envie de gagner on a tous envie d'être
performant
c'est le public qui en décident malgré
tout mais ils ont surtout envie
d'être sur scène je pense que c'est ça
aussi et ils ont envie d'être de montrer
ce qu'ils savent faire et de montrer
leur justement de quoi ils sont faits de
quoi de quelles matières premières ils
sont conçus alors cette 19ème édition a
réuni 15 collèges 250 collégiens qui ont
participé à ce cycle mille 2018 c'est
une année de travail
oui le site mythe c'est une année de
travail c'est surtout cette année ça a
été la première année où on avait autant
d'établissements scolaires c'est à dire
que saint quentin s'est agrandie ces
derniers temps donc le cycle mais aussi
par la force des choses on a
effectivement les clayes-sous-bois la
mare au sol les prêts qui nous ont
rejoints donc on espère encore un peu
d'ouverture pour l'année prochaine mais
c'est beaucoup de travail ces 30 heures
d'atelier par par établissement c'est au
moins trois spectacles pour chacun des
établissements tout au long de l'année
donc ça organise bien le rythme scolaire
aussi ça fait s'est parfaitement intégré
dans leur alors dans leur cursus c'est
très très enrichissant pour pour ceux
qui mangent rien je rappelle que le
cycliste c'est le championnat inter
collèges de match d'improvisation
théâtrale donc les phases finales se
déroulent à partir de demain c'est
demain à 20h30 à la merise lucas
mérienne vous ça s'est déroulé comment
cette année
comment finalement vous êtes arrivé à ce
stade des demi finales s'est bien
déroulé on a été à beaucoup entraîné
donc on a été un cours par semaine
toutes les semaines meriem la
préparation vous l'avez ressenti comment
où ben comme une préparation habituelle
mais cette année l'équipe a été un peu
plus soudé que les années précédentes
je pense que ça a plus eu ça nous a plus
fait pour gagner en fait vu il nous
reste un peu plus d'une minute dans cet
entretien sur la forme comment se
déroule un match d'improvisation
qu'est-ce qui départage finalement les
élèves demain pour ceux qui viendront à
la finale ils verront qu'il ya
effectivement deux équipes qui se
représentait de part et d'autre d'une
patinoire
il ya un arbitre qui est là qui va
donner un thème et après pour départager
les équipes effectivement elles vont
improviser où l'une après l'autre ou en
même temps sur le thème les équipes je
dis bien et à l'issue de chaque
improvisation en fait l'art 8 va
demander
vote au public avec un carton bicolore
et en fonction de la couleur dominante
en fait on décide de quelle équipe prend
le point donc voilà une demi finale ça
va durer 30 minutes demain finale
peut-être un petit peu plus il ya aussi
une autre manière de
d'engranger des points en fait c'est
l'équipe qui fait des fautes parce qu'il
ya des règles du jeu à respecter défaut
de la construction de l'histoire de
compréhension du public des fautes de
procédure aussi sur les tenues sur sur
la rigueur de jeu et après une équipe
qui totalise 3 fautes en fait d'un point
à l'autre équipe nombre d'accords ça
peut ça peut vite basculer après ces
deux là je les a à l'oeil parce
qu'aujourd'hui elles sont en train de
dire on veut gagner on veut gagner mais
on peut pas gagner à tout prix
ils peuvent avoir envie de gagner c'est
pas c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas c'est
pas mauvais je profite de cette minute
mais c'est vraiment un jeu qui s'appuie
sur l'accompagnement de l'autre équipe
c'est vraiment pas un jeu où on s'écrase
sinon c'est sanctionner juste rien donc
même s'ils ont envie de gagner et ça se
comprend ils peuvent pas le faire au
détriment de l'autre équipe tout ça ça
se fait en parfait de construction avec
l'autre équipe et le public décide au
final de quillan et on vous souhaite en
tout cas bonne chance on souhaite bonne
chance aux élèves du collège de la
jourée à l'ensemble des élèves pour
demain c'est phase finale du site me
2018 qui se déroule à 20h30 à la merise
attrape les infos sont à retrouver sur
le site qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
et l'événement sera retransmis un sur tv
78 et samedis 23 et 30 juin deux
diffusions à partir de 20h30 merci
d'avoir été avec nous mais c'est vous
la dernière édition a attiré l'oeil de
plus de 3 milliards de téléspectateurs
la coupe du monde de football déchaîne
les passions à l'occasion de l'ouverture
du mondial en russie ce jeudi à notre
dossier de la rédaction est consacrée à
l'événement dans les yvelines promis
focus ce soit avec des supporters de
l'équipe de france dont l'engouement
monte à quelques jours du premier match
des bleus face à l'australie et michael
lynne oraux et nicolas d'andrus
des autographes des photos des échanges
entre les joueurs et les supporters ils
étaient plus d'une centaine à venir
rencontrer les hommes de didier
deschamps à clairefontaine
l'accueil toujours extrait on est on est
là pour la france un dernier
entraînement ouvert au public avant le
départ pour la coupe du monde en russie
les bleues ont pu constater la ferveur
autour de l'équipe de france passe voilà
on est soutenus non on est soutenus nous
apprend pas voilà toujours à plus de
rencontrer des supporters on passe un
bon moment avec nous permet d'avoir tout
le monde qui est derrière
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour mettre l'ambiance les bleus peuvent
compter sur les irrésistibles français
ce groupe de supporters créé en 2002
compte plus de 1000 adhérents parmi eux
ce couple de maurepas sylvain et
jennifer charvaux pas la possibilité
d'aller en russie
donc on veut leur montrer que nous mêmes
restant en france qu'on va on est là et
on sera toujours derrière quoi qu'il
arrive même si le parcours même si la
ramène pas c'est pas avec lui
jennifer et sylvain ont rejoint les
irrésistibles français pour l'ambiance
participation au match rencontre avec
les joueurs dédicaces des maillots de
nombreux souvenirs conservés on a
quelques autres graves dont sud olivier
girault ici et de griezmann
ici le 12 juillet 98 c'était le plus
beau jour du foot français
vingt ans après ce titre ils attendent
une performance des hommes de didier
deschamps durant ce mondial avec
beaucoup d'émotion stressant énormément
stressant chaque commune voilà comme
chaque coupe du monde chaque coupe
d'europe on aimerait la voir au plus
haut plus haut comme en 98 euros vise
ces expériences là c'est c'est
magnifique et c'est pour ça nous on se
bat pour ça le foot nous donne tellement
de joie que ça vient d'une passion
autour de ce sport vécu en couple
jennifer et sylvain reste en france mais
leur coeur bat pour les bleus en russie
on va gagner j'ai un déplacement des
épreuves à l'hippodrome de longchamp
était un temps évoquée finalement ce
sera bien le château de versailles qui
accueillera la compétition d'équitation
pour les jo de 2024 à paris est le
comité d'organisation vient de confirmer
son choix
une volonté affichée mettre en avant des
sites historiques et emblématique de
paris et sa banlieue versailles qui sera
également le théâtre des épreuves de
cyclisme sur route et de pentathlon
moderne pour ces jo
ce week-end plaisir organisait la 17e
édition du festival escales d'ailleurs
musique jeux manèges ou encore des
déambulations étaient au programme au
parc du château
embarquement immédiat avec nicolas
landry
ça swingue et ce samedi 9 juin au
château de plaisir une escale dans la
nouvelle orléans de louis armstrong
trombone clarinette banjo le jazz déçoit
si swingers à rythmer cette fin d'après
midi un groupe invité par la ville
effectivement j'avais déjà vu des
teasers j'ai vu également que d'autres
nantais était venu ici parce que voilà
les associations garçons sont en tête et
en plus il fait beau tout que c'est
agréable les gens nous écoutent
[Musique]
j'ai aimé aussi bien le côté
instrumental que que là les mélodies que
les paroles c'était très bien autre
curiosité les jeux en bois pour les
enfants
la déambulation de cet oiseau à la
recherche de nourriture ou encore des
véhicules originaux construit à partir
de matières recyclées
à chaque fois il ya des nouvelles
propositions d'activités l'originalité
des les activités proposées
ça me fait du bien d'avoir un événement
comme ça chaque année dans notre ville à
l'origine de ce festival une légende un
fantôme vivrait à l'intérieur du château
seuil à sainte marie de la crâne qui
était un corsaire du roi louis xiii et
il est parti loin avec son bateau il
nous a ramené des coffres avec plein de
choses différentes du monde entier c'est
pour ça qu'on a créé escale d'ailleurs
pour cette 17e édition le corsair a fait
une apparition pour rencontrer les
quelques 10000 visiteurs des escales
d'ailleurs enfin à réunir les
générations c'était l'objectif de
maurepas en fête samedi dernier une
édition qui avait pour thème cette année
le cinéma retour avec nicolas landry et
toki nirhy lanto motor action à maurepas
le septième art créé des liens entre les
habitants
lucky luke mickey vice versa jeunes et
moins jeunes se retrouvent autour des
films d'animation on avait une activité
on devrait retrouver les émotions
dans le film vice versa je trouve ça
grave c'est comme ça
on peut faire des activités qu'on n'est
pas la maison
jean ya qualité
je jouais le rôle de maurepas en fait
c'était aussi l'occasion de connaître
d'illustrer habitants de la ville pour
cette fête intergénération la
municipalité satisfaite pas et dernière
nous avions fêté ici même place riboud
les 50 ans de maurepas dans la ville
nouvelle et cet événement avait
rencontré un très grand succès et on a
décidé de reproduire maintenant cette
année d'en faire un événement récurrent
tous les ans à maurepas que nous avons
appelée maurepas en fête est donc une
fête populaire adressé à toutes les
familles rassembler et faire sourire
la mission semble réussie pour la ville
maurepas en fête sera de retour en 2019
c'est la fin de ce journal belle soirée
sur tv 78
[Musique]